la séance est ouverte
le compte rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribuée nous
n'avons pas reçu
d'observation il y en a-t-il en séance
je n'en vois pas ne procès verbal n'est
donc adopté sous les réserves d'usage
notre ordre du jour appelle l'examen de
la motion présentée par
les présidents Patrick canaire la
présidente
et plusieurs de leurs collègues
pendant à proposer au président de la
République de soumettre au référendum le
projet de loi de financement
rectificatif
de la sécurité sociale pour 2023 je vais
immédiatement donner la parole au
président Kanner auteur de la motion
monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
allez-y monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Ministre madame
et monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues au nom de ma collègue Eliane
assassy présidente et de son groupe CRCE
et oui au nom du Président Guillaume
Gontard et de son groupe geste et des
élus de mon groupe sers j'ai l'honneur
de vous présenter cette notion tendant à
proposer au président de la République
de soumettre au référendum ce projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale rectificative pour 2023
toute la bataille menée depuis le 19e
siècle se trouve ainsi résumé la
bataille pour le temps de vivre la
conquête du temps de vie quel était
cette vie pour un prolétaire au 19e
siècle il n'y avait pas de retraite à la
fin de la vie il n'y avait pas de
journée de repos il n'y avait pas de
week-end
42 ans plus tard mes chers collègues ces
mots du président François Mitterrand
pendant sa campagne présidentielle de 81
résonne avec force dans notre hémicycle
il raisonne aussi dans mon histoire
personnelle moi enfant du Nord ce
département où les gens ont deux ans
d'espérance de vie de moins que la
moyenne nationale je sais ce que voulait
dire le mot travail dans le bassin
minier à Denain ou Douai dans les usines
textiles de l'île Roubaix au Tourcoing
ou dans l'industrie métallurgique à
Maubeuge ou Dunkerque
le combat de ma famille politique depuis
le premier jour a été de conquérir un
peu de temps de vivre il a fallu
toujours par tout temps sous tous les
régimes politiques arrachés aux
puissants les concessions qu'il
refusaient aujourd'hui se tiennent face
à moi ceux qui veulent revenir sur ces
conquêtes sociales toujours pour les
mêmes raisons l'argent la rentabilité
quoi qu'il en coûte sur le plan social
ce sont le président de la République
la première ministre est son
gouvernement monsieur le ministre les
majorités de droite qu'elles soient
relatives à l'Assemblée nationale ou
indiscutable au Sénat c'est force ne
sont pas simplement face à nous par le
menteur de gauche cela n'aurait pas
beaucoup d'importance elles sont face
aux Français en opposition frontale
aujourd'hui nous nous battons pas pour
leur arracher de nouvelles concessions
nous aurions préféré finalement nous
nous battons pour qu'il n'arrachent pas
du temps de vivre français que pour des
économies budgétaires ils ne mettent pas
en place un nouvel impôt sur la vie
d'autres politiques bien plus solidaires
sont possibles ils ont malheureusement
choisi l'injustice plutôt que l'équité
la retraite par répartition mes chers
collègues est un des piliers de notre
système de protection sociale ce sont
les luttes sociales successives qui
l'ont forgé les périodes historiques qui
l'ont renforcé on peut citer ici la
libération et ces jours heureux et 81 et
ses grandes conquêtes sociales avec ce
texte
vous ne vous attaquez pas seulement en
français vous vous attaquez aussi un pan
de notre histoire
certes il n'y a rien d'étonnant à ce que
la droite tente de détricoter notre
modèle social c'est même son fonds de
commerce le gouvernement comme la
majorité sanatoriale sont dans leur rôle
le fer ainsi en revanche est inédit
choisir une procédure parlementaire qui
fait obstacle à la tenue d'un débat
parlementaire serein éclairé et sincère
pour une réforme une telle importance
sans parler des risques
d'inconstitutionnalité cette inédit
fragiliser notre pays avec un texte qui
semble avoir été griffonné sur un bout
de table tant ces auteurs dans maîtrise
pas des contours exacts c'est inédit
faire émerger un front syndical uni tant
la concentration est ratée sinon
existante c'est inédit réussir à
coaliser une écrasante majorité de
Français même parmi vos électeurs du
premier tour cette inédit je pourrais
continuer comme cela longtemps revenons
sur quelques points que je viens
d'évoquer avant d'en détailler d'autres
vous avez choisi le détourner l'objectif
de l'article 47 1 de la Constitution
pour contourner le Parlement j'ai parlé
hier de piraterie parlementaire je
persiste et signe ces lois de
financement au sein de notre
Constitution ne sont pas faites pour
mettre en place une réforme de grande
ampleur de notre système de retraite en
ayant cette procédure vous aboutissez un
examen trop rapide et un complet d'une
réforme sociale importante qui relève de
la loi ordinaire une réforme qui aurait
dû d'ailleurs et ça a été dit hier
précédé d'une grande réflexion sur la
place du travail dans notre société la
place des seniors l'égalité femme homme
en terme de salaire par exemple avec
cette procédure ce texte pourrait
potentiellement être promulgué sans
aucun vote d'une des deux chambres c'est
un scandale c'est un bras de fer que
vous engagez avec les Français le
représentant mais vous ne trompez
personne vous faites cela Monsieur le
Ministre car vous n'avez pas de majorité
parlementaire propre pour faire voter
votre réforme par ailleurs en utilisant
cette procédure vous prenez le risque
que le Conseil constitutionnel censure
les cavaliers sociaux comme vous a
d'ailleurs prévenu le Conseil d'État si
ce projet de loi est voté il pourrait
vous être reproché que ces dispositifs
n'ont pas un effet suffisamment direct
sur les recettes ou les dépenses de la
sécurité sociale quand on enlève assez
sucrettes il ne restera plus que la
pilule amère
outre les risques d'inconstitutionnalité
que je viens d'évoquer le choix de ces
modalités de débat abîment notre
démocratie que l'on soit clair on
empêchant le temps nécessaire à un débat
de qualité le gouvernement est le
premier comptable de la dégradation du
climat autour de ce débat parlementaire
l'obstruction c'est d'abord vous les
débats tronqués c'est d'abord vous le
passage en force est d'abord vous
ensuite avec ce texte on ne sait pas si
vous êtes coupable du prix ou
d'incompétence tant vous avez varié dans
vos explications cela fait plusieurs
semaines que vous naviguez de
contre-vérité en approximation que ce
soit sur la retraite La retraite des
femmes sur les 1200 euros de pension
minimale vous semblez mal connaître
votre texte et vous découvrez ces effets
négatifs au fur et à mesure de son
examen surtout quand nos collègues
députés vont aller chercher les
informations à la source et voyez à quoi
je peux faire allusion s'ensuit une
litanie de mensonges pour camoufler vos
insuffisances et votre politique
antisociale je ne m'attarde pas sur ces
points ils seront largement débattus ces
prochains jours mais s'attaquer avec
autant de légèreté à la retraite par
répartition est inacceptable nous sommes
face à un mécano bancal élaboré par des
bricoleurs
je l'ai dit vous n'avez pas de majorité
propre au Parlement pour faire cette
réforme la seule majorité que vous avez
elle est contre vous contre cette
réforme ce sont les Français le front
syndical uni et il faut le souligner a
permis de faire émerger une mobilisation
inédite Pacifique la plus forte depuis
30 ans le 7 mars prochain le monde du
travail réaffirmera haut et fort dans la
rue son opposition au report de l'âge
légal de départ nous sommes aussi leur
porte-voix et pour dire non à la
retraite à 64 ans
mes chers collègues monsieur le ministre
écoutez les Français ils ont un discours
clair et net de refus de votre réforme
injuste entendez-vous aussi les paroles
des salariés qui disent cette réforme on
ne peut pas on ne tiendra pas jusque là
s'il s'oppose à ce point à votre projet
c'est qu'il perd sa jour vos intentions
profondes ils savent que vous êtes en
train de faire des économies sur le dos
des ouvriers les employés qu'ils soient
issus de la classe populaire comme de la
classe moyenne cette obsession du moins
d'impôt obsession du moins d'impôts de
plus en plus dénoncé par les autorités
de régulation financière vous voulez
finalement la faire supporter à six
Français actifs sur 10 soit 18 millions
de nos concitoyens sans aucun effort
demandé à cet extrait minorité de
contribuables qui a tant bénéficié de
l'hyper bouclier fiscale du président de
la République depuis 2017
cela peuvent dormir en paix mes chers
collègues Emmanuel Macron veille à leur
intérêt
les Français ont bien compris que le
ruissellement c'était pour les autres
le président de la République a été élu
pour faire barrage à l'extrême droite
les Français ne lui ont pas donné le
dommageurité pour une telle régression
sociale c'est pour cette raison que vous
ne pourrez pas faire passer cette
réforme uniquement et autrement que en
brutalisant la République avec cette
réforme pour résumer vous jouez avec le
feu tant sur la forme que sur la je le
fond et vous savez qui risque d'en
profiter sur le plan politique nous
appelons retrait de cette réforme mes
chers collègues c'est clair et net mais
faute de retrait nous vous offrons une
autre voie nos trois groupes de gauche
vous offrent une autre voie avec cette
motion référendaire je demande au
gouvernement de montrer son visage et
d'assumer franchement sa politique face
aux Français présenter leur le texte ils
sont dans la rue ils préféreraient aller
sûrement aux urnes mon appel s'adresse
aussi à la majorité sénatoriale qui a
les moyens de voter cette motion faites
honneur à votre famille politique au
gaullisme vous qui chaque année répétez
que la réforme de notre système de
retraite est indispensable pour que les
Français continuent à avoir une retraite
faites trancher cette question
fondamentale par un référendum comme le
permet la constitution imaginée par le
général de Gaulle
mais dernier mot monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
mes derniers mots seront pour le
président de la République lui-même
ce président de la République qui a osé
appeler il y a quelques jours au bon
sens des Français pour défendre sa
réforme le bon sens est de retirer cette
réforme à défaut à défaut
à défaut d'avoir le courage de la
présenter devant les Français mes chers
collègues au nom de nos trois groupes et
pour toutes ces raisons j'encourage la
Haute Assemblée à voter cette notion
référendaire merci monsieur le président
je vais donner la parole à Madame la
rapporteur général de la commission des
affaires sociales Madame Elisabeth
Doisneau
madame la rapporteur général merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le vice-président de
la commission des affaires sociales
monsieur le rapporteur de la branche
vieillesse mes chers collègues monsieur
le Président Kanner vous venez de
présenter au nom de votre groupe et
celui de la présidente Eliana celle-ci
et du président Guillaume Gontard cette
motion référendaire
nous nous y attendions ce n'est pas une
surprise vous dire si c'est une
un outil on va pas appeler ça une arme
de destruction majeure sans doute pas
sans doute pas chacun
use des outils qu'il a dans sa boîte à
outils
je voudrais je voudrais vous faire part
de deux de deux éléments d'abord une
incompréhension et d'autre part une
conviction pourquoi une incompréhension
parce que monsieur le Président kaner je
sais combien vous êtes attachés à la
démocratie parlementaire vous avez
tellement d'occasions de le montrer vous
avez tellement d'occasions de le prouver
et là aujourd'hui vous nous proposez
finalement un court-circuit on ne
débattrait pas au Parlement on
laisserait la rue choisir pour pour les
Français
alors je vois que ça vous fait réagir
c'est bien c'est bien ça fait réagir ça
fait réagir mais moi je voudrais vous
rappeler monsieur Kanner les paroles de
François Hollande qui était de gauche il
me semble et qui disait il faut
respecter la démocratie représentative
pourquoi élire des députés pourquoi
élire des sénateurs si toutes les
questions peuvent être posées au peuple
français et cette François Hollande
[Applaudissements]
alors revenons à notre sujet si on
posait la question aux Français
voulez-vous de cette loi vous savez bien
que c'est une question binaire oui ou
non répondre à une telle question
évidemment demander des efforts aux
Français ils vont répondre non et
d'ailleurs les sondages le montrent mais
si on leur dit voulez-vous sauver votre
système de réforme par répartition il
vous diront oui est-ce que vous voulez
laisser la dette de vos comment retraite
et celles et vos propres
pensions
est-ce que vous voulez leur laisser ils
diront non
donc je pense qu'il faut être attentif
il faut être attentif aux questions que
l'on pose lors d'un référendum et en
tout cas je ne pense pas qu'ici ce soit
une solution à adopter ma conviction
c'est que nous avons aujourd'hui un mur
de dette et ça c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est encore un socialiste c'est bien
Moscovici le président du Haut Conseil
des finances publiques nous dit que nous
avons un mur de dette et que nous avons
une montagne d'investissement une
montagne d'investissement pour les
armées pour le climat pour restaurer le
service public bref nous avons des
investissements à faire 155 milliards de
dettes encore à amortir sur la Cadès
vous imaginez un petit peu la somme que
ça fait et donc moi je veux pas laisser
cette décision cette décision qui est
lourde j'en prends la responsabilité je
ne veux pas donner voilà au peuple
français cette responsabilité parce que
j'estime que nous avons à la prendre ici
au Parlement
je voudrais je voudrais aussi terminer
et je veux pas parapher phrasé le
président Chirac qui disait la maison
brûle et nous regardons ailleurs mais là
en tout cas nous oublions la dette et
nous regardons ailleurs je vous propose
de rejeter cette notion de référendaire
merci Madame la rapporteur général
[Applaudissements]
monsieur je donne la parole au
rapporteur de la branche vieillesse
de la commission des affaires sociales
monsieur René Paul Savary merci
merci
oui effectivement on peut se poser la
question référendaire c'est tout à fait
légitime cela voudrait dire que l'on
propose au peuple le texte sur lequel
nous sommes amenés à délibérer la
démocratie est ainsi faite donc nous
refusons le débat nous proposons au
peuple le texte de loi tel qu'il est
ainsi formulé en conséquence ce n'est
pas prendre en compte toutes les
avancées de justice sociale que nous
proposons c'est pas prendre en compte
les forces supplémentaires
des mères de famille que nous
récompensant à travers une mesure tout à
fait significative avec une pension
meilleure ce n'est pas prendre en compte
suffisamment l'usure professionnelle qui
sera améliorée par rapport au texte dans
ce que nous proposons c'est ne pas
prendre en compte les avancées de
justice en ce qui concerne une
amélioration du dispositif de retraite
progressive et en conséquence c'est une
question brute de décoffrage que vous
refusez aujourd'hui de débattre
deuxièmement nous connaissons l'esprit
des Français toujours un peu
franchouillard gaulois et qui ne
répondent pas qui ne répondent pas
forcément directement à la question et
le référendum est si sensible à la façon
de poser la question
si vous leur aviez posé la question
quand vous avez fait la réforme Touraine
pourquoi vous ne l'avez pas fait vous
l'aurez rien demandé quoi que l'on
travaille de 41 ans et demi à 43 ans
parce que c'est ça la réalité vous
leurriez demander quoi aux Français aux
jeunes de saison vous savez ce qu'on
catastrophe avant la fin de leur année à
votre loi assez jeune de 16 ans vous
leur auriez proposé êtes-vous d'accord
de travailler 45 ans
dans la loi là
on leur propose de travailler moins
voilà la façon de poser la question et
si demain vous leur dites ici demain
vous leur dites on a des difficultés
mais voyez-vous on veut pas fait
d'efforts est-ce que vous voulez
travailler de 62 passer de 62 à 64 ans
ce serait la façon dont vous poseriez la
question moi je la poserai pas comme ça
je dirais écoutez si nous prenons pas
nos responsabilités est-ce que vous
voulez que nos enfants travaillent 65
ans plutôt que 64 ans et vous verrez que
la réponse sera différente et si vous
avez entendu
si vous avez entendu
différentes manifestations nous les
avons entendues mais nous avons aussi
écouté les syndicats que nous disent les
syndicats que nous dit la CGT que nous
dit la CFDT il faut débattre du texte
il faut débattre du texte j'étais encore
en discussion avec une déléguée CGT de
mon département elle m'a dit monsieur le
sénateur faut débattre du texte nous
suivons les syndicats nous suivons les
syndicats
en conséquence vous l'avez bien compris
je ne laisserai pas planer le suspense
plus longtemps j'ai aimé un avis
défavorable
c'est monsieur le rapporteur
[Applaudissements]
ministre
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
Jean-Baptiste Lemoine pour le groupe tu
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant
[Applaudissements]
vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président madame le rapporteur général
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègue
évidemment les sénateurs ne peuvent pas
se décharger de leur mission d'examen de
débat de vote d'un tel projet de loi ce
serait purement et simplement
démissionner et alors que le débat
s'engage à peine vous proposez de
l'interrompre en effet c'est l'article
68 de notre règlement en cas d'adoption
de cette notion que se passerait-il elle
suspend les débats elle va l'Assemblée
nationale son sort est connue bref tout
ça pour ça et je rappelle que le Sénat
un rôle tout particulier en ce moment
celui de débattre des 20 articles du
projet de loi parce que ça n'a pas pu
être fait à l'Assemblée nationale ou
seulement deux des 20 articles ont été
examinés d'ailleurs tant Philippe
Martinez que Laurent Berger le
regrettait je cite ce dernier qui dit
qui a parlé d'un spectacle indigne et
honteux
et donc ce souhait d'un débat au fond du
texte c'est pas une lubie ni de la
majorité présidentielle ni de la
majorité sénatoriale c'est un devoir
vis-à-vis des partenaires sociaux c'est
un devoir vis-à-vis des Français et
hélas avec cette motion voulait esquiver
le débat preuve aussi en est le dépôt
d'amendement par milliers parce que
votre ligne elle est simple elle est pas
bougée pas fâchée mais les Français vous
disent aussi pas gouverner depuis deux
présidentielles et donc nous nous avons
une conscience aiguë de la nécessité
d'agir également une conviction que le
Parlement peut être utile et donc nous
ne pouvons accepter cette motion
d'ailleurs si je refais un peu le film
des derniers débats
que ne l'avez-vous utilisé écoutez les
Français nous dit le président kaner
mais moi je me souviens que le président
Milon en 2016 sur la loi travail qui
mettait en place une véritable
révolution que pernicienne vous savez
grâce à la loi travail on peut
travailler 46 heures par semaine pendant
12 semaines est-ce que vous les proposer
au référendum non de Français sur trois
à l'époque voulait le retrait de cette
loi avez-vous fait un référendum à
nouveau non et puis si on parle des
retraites la loi Touraine en 2014 elle
augmentait la durée d'assurance à 43 ans
la présidente Laurence Cohen à l'époque
disait ça va frapper de plein fouet les
femmes vous en faites aujourd'hui un
choix de société lavez-vous soumis à
référendum à l'époque non alors je
reconnais la constance du groupe CRCE
parce que le groupe CRCE déposait
d'émotion portait le faire mais du côté
des socialistes on peut pas dire qu'il y
a cette cohérence et cette constance et
puis pardon mais si on parle de la
retraite à 60 ans en 81
elle a été instituée non pas par
référendum même pas par débat
parlementaires par ordonnance le
Parlement a été mis hors d'état de
débattre à l'époque
et à l'époque et à l'époque
Robert Lyon directeur de cabinet du
premier ministre avertissait sur les
risques d'une retraite à 60 ans dans son
rapport vieillir demain je vous y
renvoie et donc on le voit si référendum
il y avait il faudrait également
soumettre
au choix des Français vos propositions
je vois le succès qu'il y aurait
êtes-vous prêt à renoncer à 10% de vos
pensions êtes-vous prêt à payer 15
milliards d'euros d'impôts
supplémentaire chaque année et puis le
référendum comment faites-vous pour
recueillir la sentiment de celles et de
ceux pour qui nous faisons cette
retraite ceux qui ont 5 mois ceux qui
ont 5 ans ceux qui ont 10 ans ceux qui
ont 15 ans qui ne peuvent pas glisser un
bulletin de vote dans un dans une urne
et qui pourtant ont le droit à une
retraite et ils n'ont pas forcément
droit justement à un régime qui aurait
failli par banqueroute alors que faire
et bien écoutez je me remets mort les
propos du testeur à la hanziani en
réponse à une motion référendaire en
2010 dans cette émission et que disait
alain Anziani il disait l'autre façon de
consulter le peuple
sur les retraites c'est l'élection
présidentielle et bien ça tombe bien le
président de la République désamant le
premier tour il a posé le sujet il a dit
ce qu'il allait faire le peuple s'est
exprimé au premier tour il a été clair
il l'a envoyé au second et puis écoutez
vous pouvez prendre le sujet par tous
les bouts vos collègues
socialistes ou sociaux-démocrates
ailleurs en Europe ils n'ont pas fait la
politique de l'autruche ils ont réformé
dans le même sens que ce que nous
proposons c'est le Portugal de José
Socratès 66 ans c'est l'Espagne de José
lui sapatero 66 ans c'est la Grèce
d'Alexis de sipras souvenez-vous ou
Syriza siriza 67 ans
alors oui il faut apporter des réponses
pour les retraités d'aujourd'hui et de
demain évite il y a urgence pour
conseiller le système
urgence pour améliorer les droits
urgences pour travailler sur ce projet
de loi le groupe RDPI votera donc compte
cette notion référendaire pour que nous
puissions poursuivre l'examen du texte
faire notre travail de parlementaire au
service des Français et c'est d'ailleurs
tout le sens de cette belle analyse
livrée dans pouvoir que je vous livre
l'article 11 puisque c'est ce celui-là
dont il s'agit doit être utilisé avec
précaution à propos de textes peu
nombreux et simple dans leur rédaction
sinon il serait préférable que la
population des français fut éclairée par
un large débat parlementaire
François Mitterrand avril 1988 alors je
le dis à nos collègues de l'opposition
soyez mitterrandien soyez à la hauteur
de votre héritage politique ne le
rengnez pas ce n'est pas une défroque un
vêtement usagé éclairé donc les Français
par ce large de bas parlementaire et
rush dans cette notion
merci merci
[Applaudissements]
donner la parole à notre collègue
Emilienne tout Mirol pour le groupe
socialiste
écologiste et républicain
la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues au lendemain de
la victoire de 1945 le gouvernement
proclame dans sa Constitution de 1946 au
sein du préambule quand la nation
garantit à tous notamment à l'enfant à
la mer et au vieux travailleurs la
protection de la santé la sécurité
matérielle le repos et les loisirs tout
être humain qui en raison son âge son
état physique ou mental de la situation
économique se trouve dans l'incapacité
de travailler a le droit d'obtenir la
collectivité des moyens convenables
d'existence les forces vives de la
résistance sont donc appliquées le
programme des jours heureux et ainsi la
France a battit la sécurité sociale et
c'est un moment historique il traduit la
solidarité en particulier grâce à la
création du système de retraite qui
permet à chacun de bénéficier de droits
acquis grâce à son travail pour profiter
de la vie c'est la solidarité
intergénérationnelle
la politique c'est changer la vie
changer la vie ici et maintenant c'était
le thème que nous portions nous les
socialistes en 1981 et c'est ce que
François Mitterrand grand fait parmi les
grandes avancées sociales il a mis en
place la retraite à 60 ans parce que
nous savions et nous savons toujours
combien de travail peut être pénible et
endommager la santé des gens il n'y a
qu'à voir 35% des ouvriers aujourd'hui
seulement travaillent au-delà de 60 ans
parce que leur santé ne leur permet pas
d'aller au-delà or ce gouvernement à lui
enlever les critères de pénibilité la
politique du gouvernement actuel c'est
de dégrader la vie notamment celle des
femmes des précaires celles dont la
carrière est longue changer la vie c'est
pour nous pour l'aide-soignante
d'Aurillac la femme de ménage de
Saint-Denis ou encore la coiffeuse de
Morlaàs si cette France du travail qui
crie sa colère dans ses cortèges dans
tous les territoires
la retraite avait été pensé comme un
nouveau salaire qui permet d'employer
librement à son rythme dans des
relations autres que des relations
marchandes au bénéfice de la société
tout entière la France tire de ces
retraités une richesse que des tableaux
comptables ne peuvent faire ressortir
ils sont ainsi le premier à être engagés
dans notre tissu associatif ils assurent
des millions d'heures de garde d'enfants
ils sont les élus de nos communes vous
allez donc réduire de deux ans leur
engagement au bénéfice de la société
contrairement au gouvernement les
Français connaissent cette richesse et
demeure attachés au système de la
sécurité sociale et de retraite ces
dernières semaines ils ont par millions
de manifesté leur rejet dans la rue et
ont rejoint le front syndical uni qui
s'est créé contre votre réforme par la
faute du gouvernement et à cause de
votre vision purement comptable nous
assistons ainsi au plus grandes
manifestations depuis 30 ans ensemble
tous luttent pour empêcher votre réforme
injuste brutale et inutile
le 7 mars les syndicats neuron diront
non le 8 mars les femmes diront non le 9
mars les étudiants diront non et enfin
le 10 mars les marches pour le climat
diront non à votre réforme injuste et
libérale vous prenez le risque par votre
dogmatisme de mettre le pays à l'arrêt
alors dans un esprit de concorde nous
vous proposons une chape à toi le
référendum c'est ici là le référendum a
été inscrit dans notre Constitution pour
que les Français puissent décider par
eux-mêmes de la voix que les politiques
doivent prendre le général de Gaulle a
part quatre fois décidé de s'en remettre
à la geste populaire les crises de la
France travaillait traversée alors ont
amené nos concitoyens à prendre leur
responsabilité pour décider de leur
avenir or l'avenir des Français c'est
précisément l'enjeu de cette réforme il
est prioritaire d'intégrer les Français
dans la discussion et de les associer à
la construction de leur futur société
aujourd'hui plus de deux tiers des
Français se pose à votre réforme
dans la rue et le gouvernement ne
dispose pas de la légitimité pour faire
cette réforme contrairement à ce que dit
le président de la République Monsieur
Macron il n'a pas été élu sur son
programme mais pour empêcher l'arrivée
au pouvoir de l'extrême droite et
d'ailleurs le président de la République
n'a pas obtenu de légitimité puisque les
législatives suivantes ne lui ont pas
donné de majorité ce qu'il oblige à
composer avec les élus de droite la
souveraineté nationale appartient au
peuple ainsi lorsque le peuple est en
désaccord avec ses représentants il ne
reste que la voix du référendum
aujourd'hui je sais qu'à ma gauche le
choix de poser la question à nos
concisolations a été prise je me tourne
alors vers ma droite par une curieuse
coïncidence que seule l'histoire s'est
créée il revient au peuple
au groupe pardon hérité du gaullisme de
trancher la question de proposer ou non
un référendum mes chers collègues il
vous appartiennent d'offrir à nouveau au
peuple les clés de son destin
à notre collègue Laurence Cohen pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste
de la parole
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre demandait un référendum sur ce
projet de recul de l'âge de départ à la
retraite sonne aujourd'hui comme une
évidence monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues de la majorité présidentielle
et sénatoriale aujourd'hui main dans la
main je vous le redis le rejet de cette
mesure provocatrice est massif dans ce
pays c'est une provocation de répondre
par l'obligation de travailler plus
longtemps à la détresse à l'angoisse de
la population frappée par la crise du
covid victime d'une précarité croissante
dans le travail et dans la vie
quotidienne et qui subit une inflation à
deux chiffres sur les produits
alimentaires et de première nécessité
c'est une provocation à l'égarder femme
déjà victimes de discrimination en
matière salariale d'évolution de
carrière plutôt que l'égalité vous
ajoutez de la maltraitance en
rallongeant soit leur travail soit leur
période de chômage car vous savez bien
qu'en reculant l'âge de la retraite
c'est le chômage des seniors que vous
prolongez le message que vous envoyé aux
femmes et des plus cyniques vous leur
dites qu'elles vont travailler plus
longtemps mais que l'écart entre leurs
pensions et celles des hommes qui
s'élèvent faut-il le rappeler à 40% va
être moindre mais ce que veulent les
femmes ce n'est pas un écart cosmétique
c'est l'égalité
depuis 2017 le président Macron a fait
de l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes une grande cause nationale alors
mettez on adéquation ces paroles et ses
actes l'égalité salariale et l'égalité
d'accès à l'emploi des femmes
permettrait de résoudre le pseudo
déficit qui justifie votre réforme
unique avec les amis de mon groupe mais
aussi de toute la gauche sénatoriale
nous sommes scandalisés par les
propositions de Monsieur Retailleau
s'appuyant sur une idéologie
familialiste nationaliste d'une époque
que je n'oser non monsieur Retailleau
les femmes ne peuvent avoir pour seule
solution afin d'éviter de travailler
jusqu'à un âge indéterminé que de faire
plus d'enfants nous vous demandons de
retirer cette proposition par dignité
c'est une provocation à l'égard de la
jeunesse durement éprouvée par le covid
par un monde incertain des guerres dans
de nombreux pays la menace d'une
troisième guerre mondiale une jeunesse
conf cette inquiétant réchauffement
climatique soumise à un parcours
scolaire et universitaire de plus en
plus sélectif dans des conditions de
plus en plus difficiles que
proposez-vous à la jeunesse un service
national universel autoritaire une forme
d'embryonnement insupportable pour
celles et ceux qui ont soif de liberté
et une carrière qui ne se terminera
qu'avec la vieillesse car quelle
étudiant pourra espérer une retraite
avant 70 ans c'est une provocation pour
les travailleuses et les travailleurs y
compris celles et ceux qui exercent des
métiers pénibles ou une carrière longue
ou maltraitez aujourd'hui celles et ceux
que vous couvriez hypocritement de
louange ses premières et premiers de
corvées durant la crise du covid oui la
colère est grande et elle s'amplifie la
mobilisation à compter du 7 mars annonce
massive c'est une très bonne nouvelle et
hier dans l'hémicycle nous avons pu
vivre cette opposition entre deux
projets de société aux antipodes dans un
clivage droite-gauche enfin assumé y
compris au bord du gouvernement Macron
et son gouvernement veut passer au
forceps en utilisant cette procédure de
l'article 47.1 si décriée depuis sa mise
en oeuvre pour l'examen de cette réforme
des retraites et qui relèvent du
détournement de procédures nous l'avons
infirmé hier vous violez la Constitution
pour imposer cette réforme vous
contraignez le Parlement vous tentez de
le soumettre et nous sommes choqués par
cette majorité sénatoriale qui avait
affiché son statut de contre-pouvoir de
lieu de résistance à l'autoritarisme de
Monsieur Macron à se mépris du Parlement
et qui aujourd'hui l'accompagne avec
complaisance et oui mes chers collègues
vous accompagnez le président de la
République dans cette mise au pas du
Parlement pire cet enjamin du Parlement
puisqu’un non soumis au vote de
l'Assemblée nationale et peut-être même
non soumis au vote des deux chambres si
le gouvernement n'ouvre pas plus de
jours de débat un débat et une adoption
CMP dominée par des parlementaires LR
pourtant perte d'influence dans
l'opinion publique c'est un renforce
institutionnelle il faut donner au
peuple les moyens d'irrésister lui
donner les moyens c'est lui donner la
parole c'est soumettre ce texte au
référendum qui ici peut oser dire alors
que plus de 90% des actifs rejettent le
texte restons-nous au Sénat validons ce
texte fondamental dans un temps
contraint et barons la route à
l'expression populaire tout vote contre
cette motion référendaire est un acte
grave contre la démocratie ça elles et
ceux qui s'interont dans ce déni de
démocratie porteront la responsabilité
de la mise à l'arrêt du pays et d'une
légitime révolte avec le groupe CRCE je
vous appelle donc solennellement à voter
cette motion référendaire sans hésiter
j'avais donné ma tour la parole à notre
collègue Olivier Hainaut pour le groupe
de l'Union centriste
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre mesdames monsieur les
rapporteurs chers collègues un premier
mot à nouveau pour saluer les
rapporteurs leur travail à la fois sur
le fond du texte mais aussi du point de
vue de l'analyse et puis sur la méthode
et saluer leur leur calme leur
modération c'est important le calmer la
modération on vient de le voir
alors capacité de d'écoute de dialogue
d'échanges et de pédagogie et même leur
sens de la formule ils viennent d'en
faire la démonstration votre travail
grandit notre institution le Sénat et
donc merci nous sommes rassemblés ce
matin pour discuter d'une motion
référendaire je veux tout de suite au
nom du groupe UC dire mais sans l'ombre
du hésitation que nous ne la voterons
pas pour des raisons
d'opportunités mais également pour des
raisons de fonds du point de vue de
l'opportunité nous sommes rassemblés
pour débattre de l'avenir de notre
système de retraite et pour nous il
serait tout à fait inopportun de refuser
ce débat s'exonérer du débat sur les
retraites ici et maintenant en
choisissant le référendum cela
reviendrait pour nous à refuser
l'obstacle et ça c'est pas une méthode
pour nous voilà pour l'opportunité sur
le fond notre groupe j'ajoute appartiens
à une tradition politique qui pense que
le référendum doit être réservé à la
matière institutionnelle pour les
questions sociétales comme pour les
questions économiques et sociales nous
pensons que c'est le rôle du Parlement
de débattre et de voter j'ajoute que
cette motion référendaire la votée
reviendrait à créer un redoutable
précédent parce que ça nous interdirait
pour longtemps de débattre des retraites
ici au Parlement parce que pourquoi on
fera un référendum maintenant et par
ensuite sur des débats comme ça et
pourquoi sur des questions aussi
essentielles que des questions
sociétales économiques et sociales on
demanderait pas systématiquement à
référendum et donc un précédent comme
cela serait tout à fait irresponsable ce
serait d'ailleurs porté un bien mauvais
coup à la démocratie parlementaire donc
pour nous c'est clairement bon à cette
notion référendaire je veux à présent
profiter de temps qu'il me reste pour
discuter du texte sur les retraites mais
aussi du contexte de ce débat
vous l'avez compris hier au travers des
interventions de Hervé Marseille et de
Jean-Marie valrownberg notre groupe
c'est clairement positionné pour cette
réforme ah oui mais alors quand on dit
oui mais quelquefois c'est un petit oui
un grand mais non là c'est une forme
d'équilibre et c'est un oui mais c'est
un oui bien sûr et un mais parce qu'il
faut améliorer ce texte ce sera
d'ailleurs dans une double volonté une
un certain équilibre bien sûr mais la
volonté d'enrichir ce texte notamment
sur les pour les femmes les familles les
carrières longues et l'emploi des
seniors nous saluons et approuvons
d'ailleurs les avancées de la Commission
en termes d'équité en termes de justice
mais nous proposerons aussi par
l'intermédiaire de quelques amendements
d'aller plus loin encore tout en
veillant à l'équilibre financier du
texte c'est fondamental cette question
de l'équilibre financier de cette
réforme parce qu'il faut qu'elle vaille
la peine sinon les Français ne
banqueraient pas de nous dire tout ça
pour ça et ils auraient raison un
système de retraite repose sur la
solidarité entre les voilà pourquoi je
ne comprends toujours pas la timidité du
gouvernement en matière de politique
familiale à l'aube de ce débat sur les
retraites le choix du gouvernement lors
du dernier PPL FSS il faut le rappeler
d'avoir privé la branche famille de 2
milliards d'euros m'apparaît encore plus
aujourd'hui totalement inapproprié c'est
pourquoi l'un de nous amendements phares
sera celui qui prévoit une mesure d'âge
ça va pas plaire sur certains bancs tout
simple la retraite à 60 ans pour les
familles de deux enfants et 64 ans pour
les familles de trois enfants et plus je
ne crains pas d'assure d'assumer on est
un certain nombre ici dans cette
hémicycle l'urgence d'une politique
familiale et nataliste au moment où la
France ne renouvelle plus les
générations avec un taux de natalité
inférieur à deux ça sonne comme une
évidence bien sûr vous l'avez compris
notre groupe est très attaché à notre
système de financement de retraite par
répartition c'est pourquoi nous voulons
aborder ce débat les yeux ouverts et en
toute lucidité se donner les moyens de
financer la retraite de plus de 20
millions de retraités et non seulement à
des films et une exigence morale qui
impose d'imposer d'anticiper les besoins
de financement croissants nous
partageons le principe que seul le
travail et je dirais même l'augmentation
de la quantité de travail produite pour
notre pays peut garantir le financement
de notre protection sociale et donc le
financement de la branche vieillesse et
des retraites mais au-delà de la
question du financement nous sommes
attachés à la valeur travail ce n'est
pas sur les bancs du groupe UC que se
fera entendre un éloge de la paresse
c'est pourquoi il nous semble
indispensable d'organiser dans les
meilleurs délais un début de base sur le
travail et la rémunération des salariés
j'ai la conviction que les partenaires
sociaux sont prêts à aborder cette
discussion en responsabilité un tel
débat sur le travail nous permettra
d'aborder dans la sérénité je le répète
cette question essentielle de l'emploi
du seniors un index le Seigneur est un
premier geste il est nécessaire mais
sera-t-il suffisant j'ai bien peur que
la réussite de cette réforme passe par
la possibilité de tous et tous de
s'épanouir dans son emploi jusqu'à 64
ans d'ailleurs pour nous le débat sur le
travail est indispensable pour preuve un
sondage publié hier démontre combien les
Françaises et les Français en viennent
parfois à douter de l'importance du
travail au lendemain de la crise covid
ainsi je ne me résous pas à lire que 58%
des Français contre 49 en 2019 voit le
travail comme une contrainte quand 42%
seulement il voit un moyen de se
réaliser ils étaient
501% en 2019 avoir un moyen de se
réaliser ce recul est alarmant pour
notre pays je refuse de compter parmi
les déclinistes mais reconnaissons que
ce changement profond s'il venait à
durer s'il est entrepôtologique est un
germe de déclin de notre pays ce débat
sur le travail dans la société posk
covid doit permettre d'approfondir de
nombreux sujets je comprends je pense au
travail de seigneur je le répète à une
augmentation des salaires à la veille du
retour de l'inflation conséquence peu
surprenantes du quoi qu'il en coûte et
de l'injection massive d'argent public
dans l'économie je pense à la pénibilité
des métiers je pense à la question des
métiers en tension je pense enfin à la
formation tout au long de la vie qui
doit donner à celles et à ceux qui en
ont la volonté de pouvoir changer de
métier le bien-être au travail
l'épanouissement au travail voilà le
défi auquel nous sommes collectivement
confrontés même si nous pensons qu'il
faut aller plus loin en termes d'équité
de justice nous faisons le pari qu'il y
aura une réforme des retraites mais au
lendemain de l'adoption de cette réforme
il y aura obligation de recoudre notre
tissu social et ce sera notre dernière
remarque au nom du groupe UC comme la
formule hier notre Président nous
demandons l'organisation d'une
conférence sociale qui pourra avoir pour
objectif la refondation du paritarisme
pour recréer la confiance dans ce pays
qui est dégradé la rémunération des
salariés et puis la place du travail
dans nos vies mais chers collègues vous
l'avez compris notre groupe a envie de
débattre d'aller au bout de ce débat de
conclure ce débat c'est le rôle et la
mission et la responsabilité du Sénat et
donc pour toutes ces raisons que je
viens dénoncer notre groupe de votre APA
cette motion référendaire je vous
remercie merci
je vais donner la parole au président
Jean-Claude roquet pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre mal à la président de la
cohésion de l'agence sociale mesdames
Messieurs le rapporteur mais chers
collègues la motion qu'on a soumettre
référendum le projet de loi de
financement rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale pour une 2023 appel de question
faut-il un débat il faut il réforme
retiennent des bas pour un groupe la
réponse est oui nous savons combien la
Constitution dont les moyennes faire
passer un texte si le gouvernement est
déterminé à le faire en espèces hier
après-midi par la double voie des
ministres nous avons ambi entendu que
compromis était souhaitable mais aussi
que la réforme était incontournable les
regards sont marqués sur le Sénat
assemblés bien souvent ça faut-il le
démontrer quel que soit le signe qui va
être le nôtre espérons qu'il soit au
moins en moins de respect ce que nous
avons pas vu à l'Assemblée nationale à
choqué beaucoup de nos concitoyens
beaucoup des groupes ça nous
travaillaient à la mort sur ce texte
depuis des semaines pour tenter
d'améliorer cette réforme des retraites
au sein du RDSE nous allons écouter
syndicats et experts la commission de
l'affaire sociale a pris sa part nous
avons déposé des amendements certains
groupes par centaines que notre
administration a enregistré jour et nuit
le renforcement du droit du Parlement
est un combat qui est le silence
toujours mené à l'occasion de chacune
des réformes constitutionnelles nous ne
pouvons pas de ce droit d'examiner un
texte fondamental comme des mêmes il ne
fait pas la limiter c'est le principe de
base de la démocratie débattre c'est
ainsi le principe de base du Big Bic
amerisme amélioré pour avancer alors ma
chère collègue doit-on prendre le risque
de reculer nécessaire et qui est
financier leur système de retraite car
oui le temps de la réforme est venu les
chiffres etcollé hier par nos collègues
rapporteurs le système sera déficitaire
de cette année à hauteur de 1 milliard
800 millions d'euros le déficit pourrait
atteindre puis de 13 milliards en 2030
la redresse simple notre régime de
retraite solidaire au point qui ne
supporte pas l'allongement de
l'espérance de vie il a le défaut de sa
qualité la solidarité
qui est au coeur de notre pacte
républicain j'ajouterai que le système
paraît partition est au cœur du pacte
social donc oui il faut les réformes
rapidement bien entendu pas n'importe
quel prix mon collègue Cavalaire qui
était interdit à la discussion générale
la rappeler regardez ce longtemps
défendu une réforme systémique pour une
retraite à point ça rancune face à
l'abandon de ce projet un temps évoqué
par le Président de la République mon
groupe ne rejette pas en bloc votre
projet monsieur le ministre qui au fond
ne fait qu'accélérer la réforme tourelle
néanmoins si nous sommes ouverts en
compromis nous avons des attentes les
carrières longues la revalorie
revalorisation des droits des femmes la
compensation de l'engagement civique la
pénibilité et l'emploi des Seigneur bien
sûr et disons-le aussi la participation
des entreprises ayant Grangé les
dividendes de conséquent en pleine crie
du pouvoir d'achat ne doit pas être
écarté il y a parfois de renaissance
lorsqu'on confronte le besoin de
financement leur système de retraite et
les chiffres des montants distribués aux
actionnaires une information
doit reposer sur l'équité c'est dans ce
sens qu'il nous faut travailler et
entendre toutes les sensibilités ici et
bien sûr écouter aussi nos concitoyens
qui s'inquiètent mais chers collègues
parce que le cadre de son rôle le RDSE
préfère le débat ainsi la grande
majorité de mon groupe ne votera pas la
motion référendaire
merci monsieur le Président
je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue un ami long pour le groupe des
Républicains
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre madame la
Présidente de la Commission d'affaires
sociales madame la rapporteur général
mesdames et messieurs monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues
déposez une motion référendaire
s'inscrirait dans une stratégie je cite
à combattre sans obstruer
stratégie ou stratagème nous sommes en
droit de nous interroger en effet les
auteurs de la motion crient au scandale
pour la logement de l'âge de la de
l'ouverture des droits à 64 ans en
disant que l'on pousse les Français à
travailler plus longtemps mais n'est-ce
pas mes chers collègues la réforme
Touraine qui prévoit une durée de
cotisation de 172 trimestres soit 43 ans
pour bénéficier d'une retraite à taux
plein or la moyenne d'âge d'entraide sur
le marché du travail est de 22 ans et si
je compte bien 22 + 43 ça fait 65
alors vous allez me répondre que les
Français peuvent toujours partir à 62
ans oui mais avec quelle retraite
n'ayant pas une retraite à taux plein
leur pension subira une décote
c'est une machine en fait à créer des
retraités plus pauvres et nous ne le
voulons pas
invoquer le référendum pour donner la
parole au peuple sur un sujet qu'il
concerne directement
témoignerait témoignerait d'une volonté
démocratique affirmée
tel est le synopsis mais qu'en est-il
vraiment monsieur le Président Kader
pourquoi déposer une motion référendaire
dont les chances d'aboutir semblent bien
mince
pourquoi déposer une telle motion qui si
elle devait aller à son terme
reviendrait à dessaisir le Parlement de
son pouvoir de débattre de son pouvoir
d'amender et donc de son pouvoir
d'améliorer un texte particulièrement
important en effet à travers le prisme
de la retraite nous parlons de travail
nous parlons d'égalité homme-femme nous
parlons de justice sociale nous parlons
de santé sujet qui m'est cher nous
parlons de vieillissement c'est donc un
projet de société qui sous-tend ce texte
et il serait illusoire et bien naïf de
penser qu'un référendum permettrait de
répondre aux différents enjeux de la
réforme des retraites
au nom d'un retour à une légitimité
populaire exprimée via un instrument de
démocratie directe la proposition de
recourir au référendum revient à
empêcher tout débat au fond
pour être pertinent et exprimer une
réelle volonté populaire le référendum
d'apporter sur des questions claires
précises concise et limitée la
complexité des situations liées à la
retraite permettent-elles de répondre à
ces exigences
ne risque-t-il pas de se muer en
plébiscite entraînant une
personnalisation extrême du débat
masquant les enjeux et cristallisant les
tensions d'une société fracturée
vous me permettrez de reprendre les
propos du professeur de microso de
microso qui lui-même a déjà été cité
hier par notre collègue Eliane assassy
je cite Dominique Rousseau la démocratie
a besoin d'institutions intermédiaire
pour fonctionner sereinement et éviter
une personnalisation excessive du
pouvoir je cite encore le référendum
laisse penser que ces institutions sont
un obstacle à la démocratie
alors qu'elles sont précisément les
instruments qui font passer de la
barbarie à la civilisation fin de
citation c'est pourquoi c'est pourquoi
je m'interroge sur cette volonté de
s'auto mutiler
après des débats affligents à
l'Assemblée nationale tout le monde l'a
dit qui ont encore davantage à son prix
l'image des parlementaires et creuser le
fossé entre élu et citoyen il est
particulièrement important voir vital
pour les démocraties représentative
d'assumer notre mission d'exprimer
clairement nos positions et de défendre
nos opinions les syndicats ont ce point
de vue jusqu'à ce jour fait preuve de
responsabilité en jouant leur rôle
les élus politiques
serait-il moins capables que les élus
professionnels de remplir les
obligations de leur mandat je pose la
question je souhaite j'espère et je suis
persuadé que tous ensemble dans cette
hémicycle nous saurons avec
détermination conviction faire évoluer
ce texte monsieur le ministre cette
réforme n'est peut-être pas proposée au
bon moment il aurait fallu que le
gouvernement prennent en compte les
propositions du Sénat beaucoup plus tôt
en effet depuis 2019 depuis 2019 la
Commission des affaires du affaires
sociales du Sénat recommande l'adoption
de la réforme paramétrique des retraites
afin de préserver la soutenabilité
financière du système et donc sa
pérennité pour le générations futures
Serge René Paul nous devons agir pour ne
pas laisser filer le déficit je vous
rappelle plus de 150 milliards d'euros
cumulés pour les 10 prochaines années et
ses prévisions sont très optimistes
puisque basées sur un taux de chômage à
4,5%
. cette réforme est donc urgente
proposée par la majorité sénatoriale
depuis plusieurs années le report de la
jegal et l'allongement la durée de
cotisation vente enfin être mis en
oeuvre mais si nous partageons la
philosophie globale du projet pour
garantir la pérennité de notre système
nous avons fait de nombreuses
propositions pour améliorer la situation
des Françaises et des Français en
particulier celle des seniors celle des
mères de famille celle des enfants
félins et celle du handicap faudra
relire le texte vous révérez que c'est
vrai ceci vous dit c'est pas vrai c'est
parce que vous n'avez pas lu nous
souhaitons également promouvoir un
système plus équitable notamment à
travers la lutte contre la fraude et la
participation de tous les salariés à
l'effort de travailler plus
nous aurons l'occasion mes chers
collègues d'y revenir en détail au cours
de l'examen des articles et des
discussions mes chers collègues nous ne
pouvons renoncer à nous prononcer sur ce
texte nous ne pouvons pas nous défausser
c'est pour toutes ces raisons que le
groupe LR ne votera pas cette motion et
que nous consacrerons le temps imparti à
un débat argumenté en nous appuyant sur
le travail considérable réalisé par nos
rapporteurs je vous remercie merci
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
Daniel Chassin pour le groupe Les
Indépendants République et territoires
ce Chassain vous avez la parole
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
madame la Présidente de la Commission
mesdames messieurs rapporteur mes chers
collègues le programme du président de
la République
candidat avait dans son programme le
départ à la retraite à 64 ans mais c'est
vrai que beaucoup ont voté pour faire
opposition au RN le Sénat
a aussi depuis plusieurs années voter un
amendement concernant cette mesure d'âge
au PLFSS pour le départ en retraite
même mes chers collègues si les comptes
de la branche retraite étaient en voie
de l'amélioration ici il serait je pense
agréable à tous de renoncer à ce projet
qui mobilise c'est vrai les syndicats
que j'ai rencontré dans mon département
et beaucoup de Français hostiles à cette
réforme
nous savons tous que la branche retraite
va se dégrader cela est confirmé encore
avec ça vient d'être dit parallèle Bion
avec
14 millions par an 2030 26 en 2040
pourquoi bien je répète ce que j'ai
quand même dit hier mais je le répète le
nombre de cotisants pour un retraité
passer de 4 en 1970 à 2 en 2000 1,7 en
2020 en
1970 l'espérance de vie était 70 ans
pour les hommes et 76 pour les femmes on
est passé à 79 et 86 nous étions à ce
moment à 4 millions de retraités on est
à 17 millions et 21 en 2030 les
générations futures risquentent plus
pouvoir assumer le régime de retraite
par répartition mais en place en 1945 si
les cotisations doivent augmenter pour
maintenir le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités d'autre part ça a été dit le
dynamisme démographique qui a été
longtemps une force de la France décroît
l'effet sont là ils nous devons débattre
pour équilibrer les retraites sans
majorer les cotisations en augmentant le
travail le plus légèrement possible afin
de maintenir les retraites par
répartition et la sécurité social c'est
pour cela que j'avais souhaité une loi
travail avec une concertation avec les
partenaires sociaux avant ce projet de
loi cela afin que les personnes
handicapées carrière longue les femmes
puissent avoir une retraite plutôt mais
aussi une meilleure prise en compte des
critères pénibilités
tout ça avec les partenaires sociaux
renforcés les trimestres octroyés pour
les enfants renforcer les emplois
seniors cumulent emploi retraite avec de
nouveaux droits pour les aidants pour
l'arrose des petites retraites
intégration d'apprentissage à ça de
trimestre etc valoriser également les
engagements au niveau associatif et bien
d'autres pour lesquels mes chers
collègues vous avez fait des amendements
sur ce texte
cela bien sûr me semble être de la
compétence des affaires sociales du
Sénat
d'autre part j'avais fait un amendement
j'ai fait un amendement de revoyure en
2027 afin de faire un bilan et pourquoi
pas rajouter en fonction des résultats
et bien un autre moyen de financement et
si amélioration mais pourquoi pas faire
marche arrière mais ça se m'étonne ré
mais pour en revenir au référendum
quelqu'un allez vous poser la question
sur le recul de l'âge légal sûrement
mais aussi est-ce que vous allez poser
la question de la suppression de la loi
Touraine mise en place sur le
quinquennat de François Hollande avec
172 trimestres 43 ans de cotisations
pour une retraite complète je rappelle
que si cette loi Touraine est conservée
en l'état pour 43 ans de cotisation 2035
et bien pour une personne née en 1961
qui a débuté son travail en 1992 à 21
ans il partira avec une retraite à taux
plein 43 ans plus tard c'est à dire en
2035 mais il aura 64 ans est-ce que
François Hollande a fait ça pour brimer
les Français mais non c'est bien pour
équilibrer les retraites les Français
savent bien qu'une réforme ne peut pas
se résumer à une simple question fermée
sur autant de projets essentiels cités
pour nos concitoyens il est donc
nécessaire d'avoir un véritable débat
démocratique c'est au Sénat que nous
pouvons amender ce texte pour mieux
tenir compte des situations
particulières par ailleurs je rappelle
que aucun des précédents projets de
réforme des retraites n'a déjà passé par
un référendum nous cédons donc débattre
amender ce texte pour une réforme la
plus juste possible le groupe Les
Indépendants rejettera cette notion de
référendum merci mon cher collègue
et donner la parole au président
Guillaume Gontard
pour le groupe écologiste solidarité
territoire
et la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
monsieur
le ministre Mesdames et Messieurs les
dames les rapporteurs l'examen d'une
motion référendaire une première dans
cette enceinte depuis une décennie est
un moment d'une extrême gravité
démocratique
nous parlementaires n'avons pas vocation
à nous dessaisir de la mission que nous
ont confié les citoyennes et les
citoyens de délibérer et voter la loi
et si nous sommes favorables à davantage
d'implication citoyennes dans la
fabrique de la loi la binarité du
référendum semble souvent peu
compatibles avec l'exercice complexe de
rédaction et de vote de la loi
alors pourquoi cette motion
tout d'abord parce que ce débat
parlementaire est une farce
le gouvernement a choisi un véhicule
législatif inadapté jamais utilisé pour
une réforme de cet ampleur qui corset le
débat dans le temps et dans l'espace en
interdisant de l'élargir au-delà des
paramètres financiers symboles s'il en
est que pour vous le nettoyage n'est
qu'un coup
au moins en son temps Édouard Philippe
avait eu le courage de proposer un vrai
projet de loi et une vision nous la
contestions évidemment mais elle avait
le mérite de proposer autre chose autre
chose qu'une réforme de comptable en
costume gris destiné à faire payer au
travailleur les cadeaux fiscaux offerts
aux entreprises et au plus aisées le
Sénat doit donc examiner et c'est une
délétère première historique Intex qui
n'a pas été voté par l'Assemblée
nationale qui doit absolument être voté
avant le 12 mars minuit faute de quoi le
carrosse redeviendra citrouille mais et
nous sommes ici en Absurdie la
citrouille peut tout de même faire
l'objet d'un examen en commission mix
paritaire ou d'une adoption par
ordonnance la Cinquième République n'est
jamais en reste pour piétiner le
Parlement mais la présidence Macron a
innové comme aucun autre avant-elle dans
la dérive autocratique d'un exécutif
hors-sol isolé dans sa tour d'ivoire
isolé ou devrais-je dire plutôt dire non
content de mépriser le Parlement de
mépriser les partenaires sociaux de
l'éveil contre vous un front social qui
comme rarement sait qui comme rarement
c'est le peuple de France tout entier
que vous méprisez depuis des mois tous
les sondages affichent une opposition
ferme et constante
oscillons entre deux tiers et les trois
quarts de nos concitoyens plus vous
méprisez leur intelligence et invoquer
le besoin de faire de la pédagogie de
votre réforme plus les Français s'y
opposent les manifestations enregistrent
semaine après semaine des records de
participation et les préavis de grève
tombent les uns après les autres pour
faire du 7 mars et de la prochaine
semaine un moment historique de
l'histoire du mouvement social alors que
nous sortons à peine de la pandémie
alors que la guerre gronde offronter
orientale de l'Europe alors que
l’inflation explose alors que la crise
climatique nous heurte plus fort que
jamais au point de nous obliger à
rationner l'eau source de toute vie vous
n'avez aucun scrupule à conduire le tout
entier au blocage mais pour quel besoin
pour quelle urgence est-ce la nécessité
d'un agenda caché de vos négociations
avec la Commission européenne ou est-ce
la seule fierté mal placée du président
de la République qui considère que le
barrage à l'extrême droite vaut à
doublement de sa Royal person et qui n'a
même pas pris la peine d'étudier la
composition de la potion qui n'entend
faire boire au pays et à laquelle il n'a
visiblement pas compris grand chose le
retrait de ces textes s'impose cependant
pour vous éviter de perdre la face nous
vous proposons une solution alternative
soumettent donc ce projet dont vous êtes
si fier à l'approbation des Françaises
et des Français ils sont 70% à le
demander 70% à vouloir se prononcer sur
cette réforme 70% à vouloir être maître
de leur propre destin 70% à vouloir
exprimer leur parfaite compréhension de
votre projet de ces prétendues mesures
de justice d'égalité femme homme et de
prise en compte de la pénibilité
tout à sa réélection dont il ne cesse de
se prévaloir abusivement Emmanuel Macron
alors interrogé sur la possibilité
d'avoir recours référendum sur la
réforme des retraites déclarer le 11
avril je n'exclut pas le référendum pour
quelques formes que ce soit je l'ai dit
je suis pour le retrouver notre
discussion ne permet de clarifier les
choses location est ici toute trouvée ce
même Emmanuel Macron qui en appelait au
bon sens des Français à l'occasion de
leur faire réellement confiance
mes chers collègues notre démocratie est
malade il est inconcevable de trouver
dans nos deux chambres une nette
majorité pour approrer j'ai rejeté par
la grande majorité de nos concitoyennes
et de nos concitoyens notre
représentativité est dramatique et notre
légitimité légitimité et menacée il
convient une fois n'est pas coutume de
nous dessaisir de cette réforme de ne
pas voter brutalement dans un déni de
démocratie manifeste cette réforme
bricolé dont personne ne veut
nous avons besoin comme le disait de
Gaulle de savoir ce qu'il en est dans
les esprits et dans les cœurs mes chers
collègues de droite soyez gaullistes
n'ayez pas peur du peuple votez cette
notion référendaire
merci je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue
Annie le héros pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
[Applaudissements]
vous avez la parole
monsieur le ministre madame la
présidente Madame la rapporteur chers
collègues dans un entretien au Monde
l'historien et sociologue Pierre aux
envallon souligne que si le président de
la République peut se prévaloir d'une
légitimité procédurale née de son
élection il lui manque la légitimité
sociale fondée sur l'intérêt général et
la perception citoyenne nombreux sont
les Français et les françaises qui ont
utilisé le bulletin de vote Macron pour
faire barrage à l'extrême droite mais
pas pour soutenir sa réforme des
retraites le président de la République
ne peut se prévaloir d'une légitimité
pour faire cette réforme alors même que
la France soulève quel sera à l'arrêt le
mardi 7 mars pour dire son opposition
cela a été rappelé notre système de
retraite est l'héritage de combat et de
conquêtes sociales passées rien ne
justifie une telle obstination
renforcer par la droite sénatoriale
notre système actuel est excellentaire
en 2022 et son évolution est contrôlée
le rapport du Conseil d'orientation des
retraits de la firme il n'y a ni urgence
ni nécessité le déficit se résorbera
grâce aux réformes entreprises pour
stabiliser la part des retraites dans
notre pays B il n'y a pas de dérapage
d'indépendance il y a nécessité
d'ajuster nos recettes nous avons des
propositions réalistes pour un
ajustement soutenable et équitable sans
imposer deux ans de travail obligatoire
pour toutes et tous la mobilisation
inédite des Français et des françaises
pour exprimer avec force et
détermination
qu'ils ne veulent pas travailler deux
années de plus alors que les conditions
de travail les rendent incapables de
poursuivre leur activité votre réforme
ne fait que des perdants certains plus
que d'autres et les plus touchés sont
les catégories populaires et les femmes
le président de la République déclarait
lui-même pendant la campagne
présidentielle de 2017 je cite après
plus de 20 ans de réforme successives le
problème des retraites n'est plus un
problème financier alors voilà
qu'aujourd'hui l'urgence financière
justifie votre choix de procédure PLFSS
rectificatif
venons-en donc à la forme tous les
Français sont concernés par les
retraites vous affirmez que le président
a été élu en connaissance de cette
réforme vous vous émettez de rappeler
que le troisième tour des élections
nationales directes de 2022 ne vous a
pas donné une majorité solide à
l'Assemblée nationale pour l'amener à
bien et nous avons ici au Sénat un texte
qui n'a pas été soumis au vote de
l'Assemblée nationale en restreignant le
temps des débats au Parlement en
utilisant l'article 47-1 de la
Constitution vous avez vous-même créé
les conditions de l'obstruction comment
pouvez-vous considérer la réforme des
retraites comme une simple rectification
budgétaire qui n'impacte d'ailleurs que
faiblement l'année 2023 alors que
voulait privez des deux meilleures
années de leur retraite l'usage de cette
procédure d'urgence et le contenu de la
loi est contesté par le Conseil d'État
et le sera bientôt par le Conseil
constitutionnel face à l'incapacité du
gouvernement de faire voter ce texte
dans les deux chambres soyez à l'écoute
de l'opposition du peuple je vous
appelle à voter cette notion
référendaire en vertu de l'article 11 de
la Constitution pour que le peuple
tranche
un référendum sur un sujet aussi
essentiel que celui des retraites
permettrait au gouvernement de vérifier
l'adhésion ou pas du peuple français et
un monsieur Macron de vérifier son
postulat d'accord tacite des Français
sur la réforme les Français et les
françaises veulent prendre leur retraite
de leur vivant nous les soutenons avec
force vous l'aurez compris notre groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
soutiendra cette motion référendaire
pour associer le peuple français à cette
réforme de société et je vous invite à
droite à vous associer en votant pour
cette notion à vous remettre au peuple
sale légitime à trancher nos débats dans
le contexte de rejet qui s'exprime dans
la rue avec une unité syndicale inédite
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre du Travail du plein
emploi et de l'insertion merci merci
monsieur le président madame la
Présidente de la de la commission madame
et Messieurs monsieur le rapporteur
quelques mots pour dire qu'évidemment
ils sont surprises le Gouvernement est
défavorable à l'adoption de la motion
référendaire qui a été proposée j'ai
entendu finalement trois arguments ou
trois questions auxquelles je souhaite
apporter les positions du gouvernement
en réponse première argument concerne la
question de la recevabilité nous avons
évoqué ce sujet hier est-ce que cette
réforme doit être portée dans le cadre
d'un projet de loi de financement la
sécurité sociale rectificative nous
avons eu l'occasion hier madame la
rapporteur général moi-même d'apporter
un centre d'éléments de réponse et de
rappeler que le cadre dans lequel nous
sommes les conséquences de cette réforme
sur les comptes sociaux pour l'année
2023 rendent à la fois légitime
recevable et donc justifier le recours à
un projet loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale il y a malgré tout et
c'est une parenthèse que je fais quelque
chose d'assez cocasse pardon pour cette
expression
répondre reprocher au gouvernement
d'avoir organisé une forme d'obstruction
pour deux raisons la première c'est que
le temps de débat dont dispose le
Parlement sur cette réforme est
supérieure au temps de débats dont ta
disposer le Parlement sur les deux
réformes précédentes et les choix fait
par le Sénat d'ouvrir un nombre de jours
supplémentaires par rapport à
l'Assemblée nationale via illustré ou
conforter celui-ci puis il y a une
deuxième raison c'est que à ma
connaissance ce n'est pas le
gouvernement qui devant l'Assemblée
nationale a déposé plus de 20000
amendements dans des séries identiques
je peux vous assurer que j'avais plus
hâte d'entrer dans les sujets de fonds
que d'examiner ces amendements
identiques la deuxième question à
laquelle je veux apporter la position du
gouvernement concerne finalement la
légitimité ou l'intérêt qu'il y a à
maintenir au Parlement cette capacité à
apporter examiner la réforme des
retraites et à travailler sur ces
questions là je crois très fortement à
cette légitime légitimité de la
démocratie représentative et du
Parlement pour débat
j'y crois parce que l'histoire est
simple nous a montré que toutes les
réformes de retraite depuis 1980 ont été
examinés par le Parlement il n'y a qu'un
légère différence ça a été évoqué par
certains orateurs puisque en 1981 la
réforme a été mise par voie d'ordonnant
mise en œuvre par voie d'ordonnance
après que le Parlement est habilité le
gouvernement elle le faire mais le
Parlement c'est toujours saisi de cette
question des retraites et a pu
accompagner mettre en oeuvre des progrès
qui sont des progrès très substantiels
pour l'ensemble des assurés je ne prends
qu'un exemple qui a été évoqué notamment
par le président requier c'est la
question des carrières longues lorsque
l'on se retourne sur un passé récent à
20 ans avant 2003 l'âge de départ à la
retraite était de 60 ans la durée de
cotisation requise était de 37 ans et
demi et dans un système tel que on le
connaissait un assurer une assuré qui
travaille qui faisait des études une
licence une maîtrise qui entrait sur le
marché du travail à 22 ans et demi
travailler très exactement 7 ans et demi
et bénéficier d'une retraite à taux
plein 60 ans et dans le même temps ces
camarades de classe à l'école pouvaient
commencer à travailler très tôt à 14 ans
à 15 ans à 16 ans et devait aller
jusqu'à 60 ans et ainsi cotiser 44 45 46
ans pour bénéficier d'une retraite à
taux plein c'est la création du
dispositif de carrière longue dans la
réforme de 2003 qui a apporté une
première réponse et depuis chaque
réforme examinée débattu adopté par le
Parlement a permis de diminuer cet écart
de durée de cotisation à l'échelle d'une
vie pour faire en sorte qu'aujourd'hui
nous arrivions à une situation et ce
sera encore plus vrai si cette réforme
est adoptée où l'écart de durée de
cotisation requise sera finalement
ramené à moins d'un an parfois à
quelques trimestres parce qu'on sait
qu'il n'y a pas de perfection à la
matière et ce seul exemple montre qu'il
y a un intérêt que le Parlement puisse
se saisir ces sujets les creuser les
amender les approfondir et apporter des
dispositions techniques qu'un examen par
voie référendaire ne permettrait pas
enfin la troisième question à laquelle
je veux apporter réponse c'est justement
quel serait l'intérêt qu'elle serait
l'utilité ou l'opportunité plutôt de la
démarche de confier cette question ce
débat et cette réforme à une question
référendaire je crois et cela a été dit
par plusieurs intervenants que la
complexité du sujet je l'ai évoqué hier
en réponse à la discussion générale à
interdit cette démarche interdit cette
démarche parce que aucune réponse
binaire ne peut constituer une réponse à
la question des retraites il a été
évoqué par plusieurs intervenants et
avec des ondes très différents la
question des femmes et en particulier la
question des maires puisque ont été
évoquées les questions relatives au
trimestre accordée et validé à
l'occasion d'une maternité ou au-delà
des trimestres raccordés pour
l'éducation des enfants je suis
convaincu mais ça peut faire l'objet
d'un débat je suis absolument convaincu
que pas un couple
aucun parent aucune femme ne décide
d'avoir un enfant pour espérer avoir en
contrepartie telle ou telle trimestre
tel ou telle majoration c'est un projet
de vie c'est un projet personnel c'est
une construction par contre je suis
absolument convaincu que la maternité
tout comme le fait d'élever des enfants
peut-être soit un frein voir un
empêchement à cotisé soit un frein à la
progression à la promotion
professionnelle et donc un facteur
d'inégalité professionnelle notre
système de retraite ne compte rien
aucune disposition qui soit de nature à
marquer créer une inégalité entre les
femmes et les hommes il traduit il
retranscrit dans le calcul des pensions
non pas une volonté d'inégalité mais
l'accumulation d'inégalité tout au long
de la vie et c'est évidemment la
question de l'égalité professionnelle
qui apportera la seule et vraie réponse
soutenable à la question de l'égalité
des pensions entre les femmes et les
hommes par contre notre système ne doit
pas s'empêcher de réparer et c'est pour
ça que j'ai dit hier combien nous
regardons avec bienveillance
l'amendement proposé par le président
d'ottaïo et adopté par la Commission des
affaires local pourquoi parce que d'une
part il permettra il permet de maintenir
un système un système qui autorise une
femme je parle uniquement des trimestres
liés à la maternité les quatre dans le
régime général des deux dans le secteur
public et cela renvoie au débat sur les
droits familiaux que j'ai évoqué
permettra à des femmes ayant des caries
compétent leur carrière évitez la décote
c'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui et
c'est pour ça que ces trimestre ont été
pensées dans un premier temps qu'on ne
me décontreparties et des trimestres qui
ne pouvaient être cotisées au moment de
la grossesse et de l'accouchement et
dans un deuxième temps comme un une
réponse peut-être aux carrière hachée
mais nous avons une situation qui fait
qu'avec l'augmentation pas celle-ci mais
l'augmentation depuis
1993 depuis 2003 pardonnez-moi de l'âge
de départ à la retraite nous avons une
situation ces trimestre dit de maternité
peuvent dans certains cas dans le cas où
les femmes ont une carrière complète ou
quasiment complète perdre d'une certaine
manière leur utilité dès lors où que la
carrière peut-être complète sans pouvoir
recours aux besoins de cette trimestre
et dans ce cas il faut se demander quel
est l'utilité de ces trimestre et
l'utilité de cette trimestre peut-être
non pas de compenser une incapacité à
cotiser pendant un temps mais à
compenser les inégalités de carrière que
peuvent encore provoquer susciter et
malheureusement le fait d'avoir des
enfants et de consacrer du temps à leur
éducation et donc l'alternative qui est
ainsi proposée à la fois maintenir ce
bénéfice de temps pour les femmes qui en
ont besoin du fait d'une carrière hachée
mais permettre à celles qui ont une
carrière complète ou quasiment complète
quelques trimestres avant l'âge
d'ouverture des droits de bénéficier
d'une surcote parce que finalement
la démonstration est peut-être un peu
simpliste si elles ont réussi à avoir
une carrière complète cela signifie que
leur grossesse leur maternité ne les a
pas empêché de mener une carrière mais
peut les avoir empêché de progresser
aussi rapidement que leurs collègues
hommes et donc permettre à ces femmes
qui ont une carrière complète ou
quasiment complète alors de bénéficier
non pas de temps validé mais d'une
surcote en termes de pension nous paraît
permettre une alternative intéressante
et
posant une première pierre une première
brique pour le chantier des droits
familiaux que nous aurons à aborder et
élaborer d'ici le pelfss 2024 j'ai pris
cet exemple qui renvoie là encore à la
complexité que j'évoquais hier pour dire
tout simplement les gens termine par là
qu'une question binaire à laquelle on
apporte une réponse par oui ou par non
est une question trop simple trop
directe et donc une opportune pour
aborder une réforme comme celle-ci je
compte plus sur la richesse des débats
du Parlement pour permettre d'améliorer
le texte
aussi monsieur le ministre
la discussion générale est donc close
nous allons passer aux explications de
vote sur la motion
donc j'ai déjà deux demandes
d'explication de vote monsieur le
collègue broyé
madame
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues bien sûr nous
sommes légitimes à débattre et
d'ailleurs nous débattrons quand il est
vrai qu'ici si on s'écoute on ne se
convainc pas
mais bien sûr aussi nous vivons une
crise démocratique d'une grande
profondeur dans l'écart entre le peuple
et le gouvernement ne cesse de
s'accroître étant l'écart entre
l'immense majorité de nos concitoyens et
la majorité de notre chambre est grand
des millions de personnes manifestent le
sentiment d'injustice sociale et d'une
profondeur rarement atteint
l'unanimité syndicale s'exprime face à
cette réforme et chers collègues si nous
ne bougeons rien le populisme s'en
nourrira
alors comment sortir de cette crise
démocratique nos collègues du groupe
centrist appelle à l'ouverture d'un
grand débat social c'est une position
que je trouve pour ma part très
intéressante et très intelligente quand
on ne peut pas parler des retraites sans
parler du travail lui-même ce que ce
texte ne permet pas parce qu'il est
inscrit dans un texte rectificatif de
finance mais cette proposition de nos
collègues sont tristes supposent une
seule chose
c'est que le débat commence par ce round
social et pas par le vote d'une loi ici
nous faisons tout à l'envers sous
l'impulsion de ce gouvernement nous
changeons le mix énergétique avant le
débat sur les choix énergétiques et nous
votons une réforme de la retraite avant
le débat sur les sujets du travail c'est
un problème démocratique qui nourrira
des populistes
des citoyens appellent à une convention
à une convention citoyenne sur ce sujet
des retraites moi j'avoue que cette idée
me séduit parce que je m'étonne jeune
sénateur qu'en aucun cas nous ne
parvenons ici à trouver des consensus et
que lorsqu'on réunit des conventions
citoyennes sur des sujets aussi délicats
que la fin de vie ou le climat il soit
capable d'élaborer ses consensus il y a
là un problème qui doit nous faire
réfléchir nous parlementaire sur cette
façon dont le débat est finalement
bloqué à l'intérieur de nos institutions
alors il reste la dernière proposition
celle du référendum elle a de grandes
inconvénients notamment par son côté
binaire mais il n'y a jamais de honte à
redonner au peuple la capacité de
décider
[Applaudissements]
mes chers collègues après chaque
élection on découvre un taux
d'abstention abyssal fait des grandes
déclarations sur la crise démocratique
et puis à peine le temps passant on
finit par oublier la gravité du
décrochage d'une large partie de notre
population notamment dans le monde
salarié avec les choix politiques du
pays
et là et pourquoi parce que depuis des
années des années sont votés des
réformes qui comme un rouleau
compresseur attaque notre modèle social
et notre modèle républicain et on peut
jamais rien on vote on fait l'alternance
ça change pas beaucoup on vote pour un
président qui nous dit mon programme
tout mon programme alors qu'il s'est
fait lire contre Marine Le Pen les gens
n'y croient plus à cette démocratie il
est donc fondamental de retrouver un
nouvel équilibre entre le choix
référendaire qui donne au peuple la
parole ou en général il vote et de
l'autre côté la démocratie
représentative si on n'avance pas sur
les deux jambes les deux vont être
affaiblis
or là de quoi s'agit-il il s'agit pas de
sous des tailles on peut toujours faire
des amendements à pellefss pour
améliorer la condition de la retraite
des femmes et ceci ou cela c'est
l'essentiel
le référendum d'avoir lieu sur
l'essentiel c'est à dire le recul de
l'âge de la retraite légale à 64 ans que
massivement notre pays refuse
et ne pas vouloir faire ça c'est creuser
la tombe de notre vision républicaine
c'est creuser la tombe de notre
démocratie alors mes amis de LR mes amis
mes collègues mais néanmoins amis de LR
je vous rappelle non seulement le
général de Gaulle mais commencez pas à
nous raconter que le référendum n'est
pas une bonne chose parce que pour pour
faire un référendum sur l'immigration
alors ça madame Pécresse tombe tambour
et trompette mais quand il s'agit de
s'opposer
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame ponce
pardonnez-moi
merci monsieur le Président alors le
constat est sans appel l'Ifop 75% des
ouvriers ont foyers 63% des cas sont
opposés à la réforme
59% sont favorables à une augmentation
des cotisations et Lab 77% des actifs
jugent la réforme injuste 66%
inefficaces 61% pas nécessaire 72% des
actifs soutiennent la mobilisation et 60
% souhaitent qu'elle se durcisse avec
des blocages aussi 59% trouve que le
responsable du conflit social et des
blocages et le gouvernement toutes ces
enquêtes ne font que mettre au grand
jour l'opposition massive et sans
équivoque de la population et des actifs
qui trouvent eux aussi que leur retrait
et non négociable la démocratie c'est le
régime du peuple pour le peuple par le
peuple et pourtant vous nier la
légitimité sociale de la population et
des syndicats majoritairement opposés au
projet revanon complète Rousseau chers
collègues millions et ce pour la seule
légitimité électorale d'avoir été élu
alors que chacun sait que vous le devez
d'abord aux circonstances du second
que ce n'était pas un blanc sain à votre
programme et certainement pas à se
prolongement de l'âge de la retraite
vous faites semblant aujourd'hui de
l'oublier vous le disiez entre les deux
tours pour demander nos voix la
population doit avoir le droit de
débattre et cette réforme de cette
réforme et retrouver la parole alors que
vous tronquez aujourd'hui le débat
parlementaire si le peuple vote contre
la réforme du gouvernement il ne vous
restera que le retrait ou de dissoudre
le peuple comme disait bertholbrest les
écologistes donc pour toutes ces raisons
soutiennent cette notion référendaire
la présidente
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues je voudrais simplement vous
rappeler que le référendum le référendum
est un outil un outil démocratique qui
permet de trancher dans un moment de
doute un certain nombre de questions et
il me semble que nous sommes au cœur de
ce doute et je pense donc que le
référendum est nécessaire alors bien
évidemment il y a des réticences du
président de la République il y a des
réticences du gouvernement pour
convoquer un référendum mais je dois
dire que ça ne m'étonne guère car ce
qu'il craignent
et un peu ce que craignent aussi nos
collègues de la majorité sénatoriale ce
qu'il craigne c'est une remise en cause
de leur légitimité or ce n'est pas le
sujet ce n'est pas du tout le sujet et
si Monsieur Macron se félicite et cela a
été dit du bon sens des Français il doit
aller donc au bout de sa logique et
favoriser l'expression de ce bon sens et
non la crainte je pense que rejeter
cette notion s'est envoyé un message
très mauvais au 90% d'actifs et aux
soins plus de 60% de Français qui
veulent le retrait de ce texte parmi
lesquels je voudrais insister parmi
lesquels des électrices et des électeurs
de Macron au premier tour de la
présidentielle mais aussi des électrices
et des électeurs qui soutiennent et ont
voté pour les candidates et candidates
de la droite qu'elle soit LR ou sans
triste aux dernières élections on peut
s'interroger sur leur niveau de
tolérance de ces électrices et ses
lecteurs car cette réforme vient
compléter des contraintes financières et
sociales qui leur sont imposés depuis
plusieurs années maintenant donc la
colère est là le ressentiment est là il
serait temps que vous sortiez de votre
bulle pour entendre non seulement les
flatteurs mais surtout en temps de
celles et ceux qui
exigent pardon le retrait de ce texte
pour notre part et nous en sommes
signataires nous soutenons cette notion
référendaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président
qu'on en arrive dans nos débats à
invoquer le général de Gaulle c'est en
général qui a un grand trouble au fond
dans l'assemblée et il y a un grand
trouble et un désordre institutionnel et
il ne date pas des débats l'Assemblée
nationale et de comportements
les comporteurs auxquels on a assisté il
vient de bien plus loin ce désordre
institutionnel c'est le chef de l'État
qui en est responsable car dès son
premier mandat il a marqué son mépris
des organisations intermédiaires il a
quasiment théorisé même et se mépris des
organisations intermédiaires il s'est
déroulé et aujourd'hui il explose à la
figure du Parlement pour contourner les
organisations parce qu'on peut on peut
mener une réforme de retraite en
négociant et en ayant au moins la
sentiment d'une partie des organisations
syndicales ça n'est pas si ancien dans
notre histoire je vous le rappelle mais
c'est pas le pari qui a été pris par le
chef de l'État c'est de les contourner
résultat un front syndical total
marquer ce gouvernement nous y habitues
avec les professions de santé c'est la
même chose il arrive à tous les liguer
contre eux et à échouer à signer un
accord conventionnel je ferme la
parenthèse mais ça n'est pas une
parenthèse c'est sa ligne de conduite et
donc il arrive au Parlement et face à un
peuple qui dit non face à des
organisations syndicales qui disent non
il imagine une procédure
institutionnelle qui est bancale sur le
plan constitutionnel et qui met le Sénat
dans la situation d'être l'Assemblée du
peuple ce que nous ne sommes pas ce que
nous ne sommes pas nous sommes la
chambre des territoires et bien c'est un
désordre institutionnel total qui a créé
le chef de l'État c'est un chaos qui ne
peut pas se résoudre de façon apaisée
par la voix parlementaire et croyez bien
que je le regrette il n'y a qu'une
solution c'est de retirer ce projet et
oui c'est d'aller vers le peuple
la parole à Monsieur pour expliquer son
vote non
mais si vous le demandez plus je
moi
j'ai entendu dans les arguments
s'opposant à cette motion référendaire
des plaidoyer pour la démocratie
parlementaire
je prends date parce que oui le
Parlement oui l'assemblée où il le Sénat
c'est le
c'est le fondement du fonctionnement
démocratique dans notre République et
donc très souvent on a dû le défendre
quand il a été brutalisé par différents
gouvernements et en particulier depuis
Emmanuel Macron cette brutalisation est
constante depuis
quelques années les procédures d'urgence
qui devaient être exceptionnelle sont la
règle sont la coutume donc mes chers
collègues qui venaient faire ses
plaidoyer et monsieur le ministre en
particulier
pourquoi à chaque fois à ce point le
brutalisé mais on est dans une situation
très particulière
on va toucher à la vie de millions de
nos concitoyens alors que le Président
de la République
dans son élection
n'a pas été investie par le peuple de
faire cette réforme et d'ailleurs s'il
l'avait été ça se serait vu au
législatives il aurait eu une majorité
et donc on est devant une réforme
majeure qui touche à la vie de millions
de nos concitoyens
et le message et le mandat parlementaire
n'est pas clair
celui du président celui de la première
ministre celui des majorités et en plus
de cela une mobilisation syndicale qui
est massive et des enquêtes d'opinion
qui touchent
disent qu'une grande majorité de
Français et contre et donc la seule
façon de dénouer cette crise cette crise
démocratique sur cette question et que
le peuple prenne la parole par voie
référendum et ça veut dire un débat dans
le pays bien entendu
je n'envoie point la discussion donc
nous allons passer
au moment du vote sur l'article unique
de la motion de renvoi référendum je
rappelle qu'en application d'article 59
du règlement de scrutin public et de
droit
donc
c'est l'article 56 du règlement qui est
appliqué maintenant le scrutin est
ouvert
personne ne demande à voter
le scrutin est clos
pardon je réouvre le scrutin
elle n'a pas été fermé alors
Kruta et clos
du scrutin
votant 344 exprimé 344 pour 93 contre
251 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
en conséquence mes chers collègues nous
allons poursuivre la discussion du
projet de loi de financement
projet de Loire
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale je
vais maintenant suspendre la séance elle
sera reprise à 17h pour l'examen des
articles mais si on s'est suspendu
chouette bon courage à la commission la
séance est suspendue